okay being 10 o'clock call this work
session to
order uh and without objection I would
like to recess for a bit and wait for
our final member who's running a little
late uh so she can get here so we'll be
in recess until Mary shows up
let
e
there is any
voting so let's let's
reconvene uh
the first bill is House Bill
601 uh relative to participation
Medicaid direct certification program
for free and reduced price School
meals now we have somebody who we held
this one because the Senate was having a
s Harry can you Harry please we're live
now okay um we held this one because the
senate had a committee meeting and they
were going to report out by November 1st
which which they've
done as it turns
out representative Pichi muler ended up
on that committee much to his
suarin uh surprise surprise so I would
ask if you if you would like to report
on behalf of the committee from and you
have copies everybody has a copy of the
report thank you Mr chair um I just need
a second to get out of my
uh okay so um the report should look
like
this you put one at your place I think
and um to make a long story short um it
was
U very useful discussion on U the
consequences of uh making uh you know
this policy change and uh the
committee with an amazingly long name I
believe it was the committee to study
the impact on snap and Medicaid changes
on free and reduced
Mill you know it it was a pretty long
one basically we had um
a very good uh set of meetings where we
um all agreed to look at the data in
specific ways and we've had a lot of
work done by the various departments
Department of Education DHHS by the LBA
staff to try to um at best as as well as
possible estimate the financial impact
of those policy decisions and there is
quite a bit of data here that I don't
really plan to go into a lot of detail
on but I will be happy to elaborate if
there are
questions um we've heard from all you
know um stakeholders that were uh
willing to testify and the report
details who spoke and why the
recommendation was to
mostly keep things the way they are and
to address a very important issue which
is
that based on our discussions there are
two different groups of uh kids who
don't end up in this program there is
the group of parents who feel
discouraged by the complexity of the
paperwork and just give up on it and
there is the group of parents who simply
doesn't want to participate and uh you
know has no interest in it and um our
major recommendation on that side is to
um look at we spoke with the Departments
the Commendation is to streamline that
form for people who are on Medicaid so
that if somebody's already on Medicaid
they should just have a form that says
this is my name I'm enrolled in Medicaid
go get my data from Medicaid and
determine my my eligibility for the
program there should be no need to
redund provide redundant information
again and again to different state
agencies to get eligible for something
doing so would also respect the right of
the parents who simply don't want to be
in the program to not want to be in the
program obviously there is a minority
and a majority report so I'm sure that
you had an opportunity to U read
it
but nobody disagreed with that
particular recommendation you know the
these agreements were in whether we
should go you know further than that
anyway because of
the impact on privacy and because of a
huge financial impact I mean the numbers
are staggering and I let Mickey describe
you know how um the um you know numbers
were obtained I believe that it would be
in the best interest of uh the state to
U you know itl this bill and I would
like to make that motion when the time
is appropriate whether it's now or later
but I would be very happy to again
answer any questions about the
discussions we had tell you exactly what
the concerns were and we do have people
who are here to provide
information
question um my question is um during our
multiple conversations we talked about
the potential of a pilot um maybe doing
a a few school districts and looking at
that using Medicaid direct
certification and um
the um using that instead of um the free
and reduced lunch forms that go out to
school parents um so instead of it Ling
it could we perhaps amend it and look at
it or interim study it amend it um and
then run it as a pilot part of the issue
is we really don't know exactly how many
kids we have an assess ment that's been
provided of potentially the greatest
amount of kids that could be
participating um in this but we don't
actually know how many some may be in
preschool some may be um older than that
right now so if we could just at least
instead of iing it at least look at
maybe the potential of a pilot with two
or three school districts um so would be
an amended document Bill and go for with
that we' we've agreed that the data that
comes is good data um that we would more
accurately know how many children are
living in poverty in the state of New
Hampshire and we really should try and
get those numbers so um if that's a
possibility but also like to at least
let us hear from Hunger Solutions so
that they could talk a little bit about
why this bill is so important
please well if someone would like to
fill that slot please join
us and thank you for being
here hi I'm Laura milikin I'm the
executive director of New Hampshire
hunger
Solutions um we have been advocating for
Medicaid direct certification so um uh
there are currently 38 States across the
country um who are participating in
Medicaid direct certification it's a way
of streamlining the process of getting
kids who are eligible um for federal
benefits to be fed in school and we know
that the uh benefits of kids eating in
school are many many um not just for
individual children but for classrooms
in the short term for academic outcomes
for the children in the short and long
term and for health Health outcomes um
for for children in the short and long
term so it's a very good
investment um in New Hampshire's future
uh to make sure all children are fed in
school the um the costs that are created
uh through Medicaid direct certification
have nothing to do with the
certification Pro uh process itself or
the meals themselves it's all about the
state's education funding formula which
uses free and reduced meals as a proxy
for measuring poverty
so I completely understand that there
are mechanisms that are in place
relative to the um education funding
formula that costs additional cost but
Medicaid direct certification is about
making sure that those children who are
eligible can access the program um and
that of course is is what we advocate
for I mean I think that it's a very good
investment even at its cost um because
uh investing in children is really
investing in in New Hampshire's future
um and that the benefits of having
children fed are many many um they're
just reams of evidence I'm happy to
provide you with that evidence if you'd
like to see
it thank you so I believe that nobody
you know on the previous committee
disagreed with the importance of kids
being fed I mean there is zero
disagreement on that I just wanted to
double check do you have right now the
Assumption seems to be that if a kid is
not on free and redu they don't get fed
do we know that to be the case because
in my personal experience which is
limited to my town where I was on the
school board so it's just one town out
of the whole state kids were never
turned down for food they may end up
with a few dollars in debt at the end of
the year because we kept track of it but
the school pretty much wrote it off so
do we have any data that that
illustrates kids actually not receiving
food at schools or is it just a general
concern because they are not on the free
and
clear I do not have any data about how
many children but uh are not being fed I
think probably there are children whose
families say to them please don't go
through the lunch line because we don't
have the money to pay for those meals um
so I think that there's you know it it's
there really no methods for measuring uh
those kids what I do know and um and I
only know it anecdotally perhaps my uh
colleagues from um New Hampshire Ed
could speak to um what they're hearing
but what we're hearing at New Hampshire
hunger Solutions is that many many
schools are um incurring quite a lot of
school meal debt because of exactly what
you're saying that schools don't want to
turn away kids who want to eat um but uh
even though kids might be eligible the
schools are having to pay for it because
they're not act those kids are not
enrolled in pre-introduced
meals thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um so we see here
that
7700 new students would with this
program would start getting free and
reduced Lune do you know how much how
many students are currently getting free
and reduced lunch and how much uh
federal funds are coming in for those
students um I I don't have the number
thank you for the question
representative I um I'm sure there are
people in this room who have the exact
answer to the question um my
understanding is there are about 42,000
kids who are currently on free and
reduced meals um 100% of the meal cost
for those children are is reimbursed by
the federal
government um so that's quite a number
of federal dollars that are flowing into
the state
um and and just to be clear the
7721 that was um estimated um those kids
are not new students those are students
who are already being served in school
districts those are kids who are living
in poverty and are being served by
schools thank you Mr chair I just want
to answer that question because we do
have the memo from the Department of
Education that has quite a bit of detail
on that and if you look at that other
memo that starts with uh you know the
one from Mark manganelo dated 10 2023
which everybody on the committee should
have if you look on the second page this
is a complicated discussion but those
are the best numbers we have the
enrollment dropped during during coid
because of
the policies policy changes on Medicaid
Eligibility that no longer required
recertification and allowed everybody to
stay on the program whether they were
eligible or not as a result there was a
drop in fnr enrollment that was larger
than the drop in Medicaid because there
was no need to re recertified so we
tried to project this on the last known
year that was solid which is the 20
school year 2020 P that the numbers are
getting skewed by the impact of the
federal policy changes so there is this
is the best analysis we have the memo
goes into quite a bit of detail on how
it was achieved and what are the
assumptions that were made they're just
the best numbers we have available but
nobody can say they're 100% accurate
it's just best effort and the best data
we have to work on with it um and that's
I just wanted to clarify that you know
question thank you Mr chair so we've got
this
blockage um where you have the
intersection of we all I appreciate you
know um representative papich mu
giving that the you know the the
subcommittee supported the idea of you
know being able to provide a better data
for children in order to get free and
reduced lunch um the blockage seems to
be that that number is used as part of
the education formula and the immediate
outcome of that right now as um M Milan
was saying is that schools are acre debt
because of that um I don't see us
getting through the blockage right now
because of the education formula is so
complicated um but and for far less than
$191
million is there an opportunity um to
provide a fund for the state to create
an order to reimburse schools for the
loss um that they incur in providing
lunches for them I mean that's sortly an
entirely different topic but I don't see
us getting through this block right now
because of the education funding formula
is set and it's complicated um it
doesn't seem like it would be a heavy
lift in order to reimburse schools for
um the free and reduced lunch for the
children who can have it and maybe that
would open up the Avenue for students um
or would give the schools some freedom
in terms of allowing students who they
know need the food um but aren't going
through the process for the the state
I'm just looking for a way to get
through this now because I think we need
to address this later we all seem to
support the idea of using um a better
information the Medicaid information for
identifying these students but right now
I think we're kind we're kind of stuck
so is there a way of helping the school
and reaching more children who are
hungry yes
can we've talked often about free and
reduced but we never separate them free
is one level of income reduced is
another and the thing we most often hear
is oh the reduced don't pay any anything
even though they're supposed to pay
something so some of this is as a result
we've heard examples before us oh we're
30,000 in debt because of the reduced
population didn't pay
anything and I think there's a confusion
among those who are on free and reduced
and does anybody have a number does does
our LBA person know any number of this
group is free and this group is reduced
and quite often the reduced group either
is not paying what they should be or
they're not paying at all but we're
hearing frequently from schools that say
with 30,000 or so many dollars in debt
from people who didn't pay on the
reduced level so do you know what those
are thank you doe can step in but I
think it's uh 85% of the number is free
and 15% or so is reduced that about am I
is that close we do you have copies for
the doe has data we can pass that
around yes go ahead Mr chair um I just
wanted to ask I don't know the answer to
this one do we have any state level data
on the total impact of you know school
lunch Deb because I know that in wiam we
just wrote it off you know we paid for
it from General funds and we were done
with it but I obviously don't want to
assume that what happens in wiam happens
everywhere else so if we have an idea of
what the impact is you
know it would be
useful good morning um Kelly Rambo from
the Department of Education Bureau of
nutrition and wellness Melissa white
division director for learner support
New Hampshire Department of Education
sorry I I don't too slowly Melissa white
y division director for learner support
y thank
you and thank you for that question um
we do not have that that data um at the
the department that's at the local level
y if I may follow up would it be
possible to ask the schools to provide
that number so that we maybe have it by
the beginning of the next budget process
because I think it would be an
useful you know data piece to help us
figure out how to fund schools properly
you know to make sure that no kid who
needs food is left without food that
should not be happening but there are a
lot of different ways to do it and to
decide how we we could really use some
detail on you know what are the maybe
ask them retroactively too for going a
few years back you know this is how much
we had every year and this is what we
did if it doesn't create too much of a
we could definitely survey the field and
a request that the local education
agencies you know voluntarily provide us
with any kind of um figures that they
have for their unpaid I think the part
that we um at the department have
reiterated a few times is that we know
the reduced lunch number so if we're
looking at a number that we're pretty
solid with as far as what we would want
to cover to meet the needs of students
we're already paying for the breakfast
portion for those students that are on
identified for reduced we could pay at
the state level for the remainder of
that reduced lunch component yeah when
we get into the um specifics of
qualifying for some of these other
programs and we're looking at Medicaid
direct certification those bring in some
different pieces but that number
specifically we do have and we do know
in that number you can see there is in
front of you so that's just something
that um I wanted to bring up because I
know that was mentioned a couple times
like what numbers can we look at to
provide that the support that we do know
that there's a need for can I ask what
what number are you using now for total
students for the state
approximately total enrollment or number
of free and reduced no total total
students how many students I think we're
around the range of 160,000 okay God
that was because I'm looking at this 40
thousand I'm
saying that's pretty close to 25% of the
student population yeah wow okay thank
you Mary thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for taking my question if in fact we
were to proceed maybe even with the
pilot um in terms of um Medicaid direct
certification um well I guess let me do
my first question first if in fact we
went to Medicaid direct certification
would it increase the amount of federal
dollars being returned to the state of
New
Hampshire in many
areas well I can only speak to um for
what it would do for the department or
the local level um related to food
Melissa can maybe speak to um the other
portion of it um but the it would go
back to the local level um if there were
students that were qualified for
Medicaid that were not already currently
on another program um they would get
Federal funding um if the state of New
Hampshire was to be
qualified um for the Medicaid for the um
USDA program but we have to be a part of
that program we cannot pilot it we
cannot look at you using a few school
districts we have to have be a part of
that program have that application
accepted by USDA before we could do
anything so if we're looking at trying
to do um some sort of pilot we're going
to need to pay for that at the state
level the feds will not reimburse us for
those costs because they do not allow us
to um use some sort of other type of
identification it has to go through
their free and reduced eligible um
form just to followup um in our
conversations when we had the um
combined committee with um education we
talked about um if in fact we were to go
with Medicaid direct certification when
individual families were signing up for
it they could be given the option of in
fact accepting or um saying that they
don't want to be part of free and
reduced lunch meals so it wouldn't be
that everybody who's identified it would
help the state if everybody's identified
is identified but at the local level
those families who don't want to be
determined as such could sign off saying
that they were not not interested and
they would do that at the time at which
they sign up for
Medicaid so unfortunately um that would
be a question for DHHS um because the
program is operated through DHHS and I I
I don't know the answer to that thank
you but I think we just want to also
reiterate that we have to be accepted
into the USDA program they have not
opened up that application period they
have said this fall they were going to
do that they still have not done that so
we don't even have the opportunity to
apply for um to be a part of the
Medicaid direct certification program
until
USDA releases that an and does a request
for applications for that and then when
they do we can apply and then kind of
move on to these next pieces but it's
difficult to kind of Jump Ahead or say
we're going to kind of create our own
system or do some or our own
certification they they're not going to
reimburse us for those those costs for
thank you I just wanted to I I hear you
and I remember that we spoke about this
obviously you know a few weeks ago that
the federal rules are you know the
federal process is the federal process
and we don't really have control over it
I do remember that we spoke about and
I'd appreciate if you confirm if my
understanding is correct or not that if
instead of doing direct certification we
are allowing people who are already
enrolled in Medicaid to just provide
that you know one checkbox form to the
school and just say I want to apply for
free and clear instead of giving you the
data I'm enrolled in Medicaid and you
have my consent to work through doe and
DHHS and get that data my understanding
is that that may be possible without new
legislation it would just be
administrative changes because you'd
have the consent of the parent to you
know share that information between the
state
agencies um so unfortunately that would
not work um because currently in the
state of New Hampshire we are not on
Medicaid at the USDA level um so the the
only programs that we operate as a uh
direct certification are snap tanif um
and that is Medicaid is not um allowed
for USDA reimbursement so unfortunately
that method would not work at this
moment in time it could be something
that that if we were on the program it
could be explored but because um that
that door isn't open for the State of
New Hampshire that um is unallowable so
just as a clarification something Chang
since the time we talked about this a
few weeks ago because when we talked
about it in committee my understanding
and the committee's understanding was
that this was a possibility because
again the parent would give you consent
to you know access their data so you
guys did more research and changed the
not until we actually are approved by
the US um agricultural Department to
participate in this program they won't
we can't do that until we're part of
that direct certification program so I
think the committee is talking about
okay a couple steps down the road when
we get to that point once we've been
accepted and USDA has approved our
ability to be a part of this program
then we can look at what that would look
like but where we're at right now is
we're not a part of it we wouldn't be
able to use the Medicaid direct
certification at this time we wouldn't
sorry I I just want to clarify because
I'm not sure I'm not asking about direct
certification right we know that we are
not in it even if we approved it today
we have no idea when it may happen
because it depends on the feds so
leaving that off the table for now we're
just talking about what we could do
today people are already enrolled in
Medicaid you know the HHS has their data
they already provided the data to the
HHS to get you know enrolled in Medicaid
right is there any roadblock between
just allowing a person who already
enrolled in Medicaid to tell the school
to you know connect through the doe to
the HHS and get all that data they
already provided instead of using a huge
application for form for the fnr that's
what I'm talking about I'm not talking
about I just want to clarify and that
the state would then pay for the entire
cost of the
meal I do not because the feds would not
that we okay so you saying that we could
do it could do that but the feds would
not recognize it correct the state would
have to pay for that
cost that's new information that I
appreciate having thank you I think the
um the confusing piece might be is that
this actual program at USDA is called
Medicaid direct certification so I think
the the title of it can also be
confusing as well too um and although
you're not speaking to the direct
certification portion of it um the
Medicaid Program for USDA um that little
checkbox when we um as the state of New
Hampshire apply for those benefits to be
able to use cross inter agency that
little checkbox at USDA is not there for
for for Medicaid so whether it's we're
using the information directly certified
and we're getting a file and and
matching or um the parents are simply
saying as as you're um identifying that
we would like to opt in or we would like
to say yes you can use that and it's not
directly certifying neither of those two
for the State of New Hampshire as USDA
recognizes to be able to get that
Federal funding back um is not
applicable at this moment in time what
Melissa is um speaking to is that if the
the state would like to go in that
direction the state would need to fund
um those those students or those kiddos
that that would be on um that would go
into that so it can be done but it's
just a question of whether you get
Federal money for it or you don't okay
so that's what's in the balance there
okay thank you I appreciate the
clarification yeah you thank you Mr
chair you I might have a little more
understanding here I hate to be the one
one that says I have no idea what this
means um but in the chart you handed out
um I can add up the numbers and I get
that but I still don't know what they
mean um the 122 million is that what
would would you walk me through this
chart so I don't have to ask questions
sure I'd be happy to um so to answer
your first question um
the 122 um million at the bottom would
be um just for complete reference if the
state was to pay for all meals for all
students that are currently um that we
have for enrollment in the state of New
Hampshire when you say all meals you
mean all 160,000 students or all 160,000
students not the 42,000 who are
currently enrolled that is correct the
chart above will break it down to um the
the free students obviously that's fully
covered by the federal
reimbursement um and then they're
reduced um and it's broken down by
breakfast and lunch because obviously
those prices are different different um
in the reimbursement that we get from
the federal department um so you can see
the meals um I'll just go through the
columns the eligible students um
currently that we have the data for
which is
2223 um the meal price after the federal
reimbursement so what I did was I took
the federal reimbursement less than um
so that would be what the cost would be
per meal to the state um and then the
the last column is the total column you
can also see already um to to Melissa
spoke to this before that um the state
is currently paying for the reduced
price breakfast for all of those
students um so that's why the total cost
at the bottom um is the 122 million and
it's less that um the what the state is
already currently paying um so you can
also see that the total for um the
breakfast and lunch for um free and
reduced would be the 87
$3,000 um and since the state is already
paying 374 of that the difference would
be the
$499 can I ask some other questions sure
so the the 499 is does that still
pertain to only the 32,000 eligible
students here or is that the 160,000
students no that is just for the reduced
priced um lunch so so that's the sorry
um so that's the actual if you look at
the reduced lunch that's
6,932 students um because the federal
government pays for all of the free
students so um so that would encumber
all of those um all of those students so
if we paid lunch and breakfast for the
32,000 students who are eligible um then
you get the 374,000 plus the $499
correct okay and the 123 is if we paid
everything for everybody so we have
one number which is kind of in the real
world and then we have a very high
estimate of if we covered everybody
um is there a way of nuancing that
because there are certainly a number of
people who would not need to pay the
whole amount I'm wondering is there a
way of just being able to reimburse
schools for their loss um as opposed to
paying free and reduce lent for
everybody even those who actually really
don't need
it um that's uh data that we would need
to collect his we don't have
that this is a situation the more you
know the Dumber you
are Mary thank you Mr
chair we know that currently there's not
a pilot program available to apply to at
the US um Department of a
agriculture if we choose to itl this
bill at this point in time we close that
option for the State of New Hampshire if
we choose to give permission to the
Department of Education to proceed with
this in the event that a pilot becomes
available to apply
for at that point in time we can always
have a conversation about do we want to
do this or not but it just seems like
we're kind of cutting our
options in terms of number one we know
the data will be better in terms of the
adequacy fund
um we know that we'll be able to feed
more children um so I hate to see us itl
this bill because we will not be even
sending a signal to the Department of
that that if in fact this becomes a
reality they can't even apply for it
because they don't have the authority to
do it so I just am am disheartened by
the fact that we would consider it Ling
601 um when it really is is putting a
roadblock in front of a lot of
possibilities Mr chairman if we did
apply how long would it
take in order for it to go into effect
it would be about two to three years
before um you know the the application
process um does take uh a year and then
um it would have to go into effect
either two or three years after that
thank you
I have to agree with representative
Murray I I think we're trying to cross a
bridge that we're not you're talking
about process you're saying we got to
get in the
process we're in
finance I'm looking at money and right
now it's a it's a $190 million decision
that we don't have in the
budget so if using this committee as as
as our screen to say that committee
recommended uh this is a pretty big bite
so I I can appreciate the process
discussion but when it gets down to are
we going to approve 190 million
additional dollars in the in the budget
that's already been voted I can't
support it so that's I'm with I'm I'm
with representative Murray we've hit an
impass because we it's so complicated
process-wise that we're we're what are
we voting on are we voting on a process
or we voting on a budget and for me I
I'm I got to look at the at the numbers
yes yeah thank you Mr chair I'm not sure
I'm on the itl point right yet but well
but I agree with you um you know my goal
is to try to find a solution um and my
goal immediately here is to try to find
a way to keep this going forward and I
don't know if there's an interim study
um I'm uncomfortable of directly moving
it Forward not just not necessarily for
the money but also um somehow tying the
Department of Education into something
that uh there may be consequences that
they're not anticipating uh that would
make it more difficult for Department of
Education to do their work I'm just
because we don't know I just have some
hesitation about binding Department of
Education as well as binding the budget
to this um so I guess you know Mickey is
sort of our expert here and perhaps some
other people would know is there a way
to keep it alive to Pro to keep the proc
to keep us aware and on top of it so
that as things happen we can respond to
that I really support the idea um but
I'm very uncomfortable with the unknowns
in terms of the money and the unknowns
in terms of the
process thank you Mr chair um two quick
things one to address the you know
comments from our colleague I believe
that whether we itl this bill or not
this is not a discussion that ending I
mean this is something that's always on
our radar we need to get more
information and decide on the right
policy to me the question about this
bill itself is whether this bill should
pass and in its current form there is no
way I can support it especially since
you know uh chairman emeric was saying
that U the money is not in the budget as
in we don't really you know have the
ability to pay for it if we pass it my
real concern though is when we passed
the budget on the house floor this was
already in it when the Senate changed
the budget they removed it but they
added even more funding through other
means so this 190 million that we are
looking to add we already added 193 plus
11.54 snap I mean the money is there it
may not be using this mechanism but to
me it would be F we would be double
counting right now if we now change the
budget at this point in time so this to
is a discussion that needs to be part of
a regular budget process I cannot
support passing this bill at this time
because of where we are in the budget
cycle and because of what we just did
this spring where we addressed it the
best we could can we do better I'm sure
that in the next year we'll try to do
even better but I don't think that it
telling this bill would in any way stop
our work in that direction because I
think everybody here recognizes the
importance of addressing those concerns
in the best way
possible we've had a lot of stuff about
childhood hunger which I believe is a
distraction in this bill there are no
hungry children in New Hampshire and in
the schools I I my own Local District
has even solicited for money from
various organizations saying there are
some children who they they don't get
paid for but I think that's a minor
amount we see all the money is that's
going for free and we see the money that
should be paid for reduce that isn't
always paid those are some Sidelines
what I want to point out is we're like
number five or six out of 50 states in
the cost per pupil I think it's
ridiculous we're paying more now than
some schools are charging for prep
schools we're paying over $220,000 per
student that's ridiculous and this is
just going to be more money we're
already overpaid in my opinion I would
never support this thank you
Dan thank you Mr chairman so am I
correct that that the amount of federal
funds per free and reduced CH child is
roughly $1,000 a
year Mr landrian maybe you could answer
or
00 okay less than less than that can you
repeat the question the amount of
federal funds that come for on all of
these free and reduced students the
42,000 students is it work out to
roughly $1,000 a year per
student it it actually depends on the um
these numbers here are if every single
student eight every S I know these I'm
asking how much federal funds are coming
it depends on the meals that are claimed
for
reimbursement all
right let me ask it a different way my
my
back of the envelope calculation is
roughly $6 a day per student times 175
days is roughly $1,000 is that correct
I'd have to do I'm not as good with math
um so I'd have I'd have to do it out um
and I don't want to answer you
incorrectly Bart correct okay fine so
what we're talking about by adding 8,000
students
is maybe we could get another eight M
we're leaving $8 million or or seven or
something worth of federal funds on the
table right but but with our current
system you know as as um representative
Amer
says it doesn't make sense to to spend
200 million to get
eight you see what I mean uh that
anyways that's my that's my argument so
these have these things have to be
coordinated with the budget right
representative Popovich Mller is
correct
here we have to make a budget
anticipating these new
students right so that it works I mean
it makes sense at some point to try to
do this to pick up that bit of federal
funds but we can't do it now right
because um because the rest of the
budget isn't coordinated with that
and all we would need to really move
forward um with the application process
is just legislation that would allow us
to just apply that that's that I think
there's more in this component of it but
any legislation that just allowed us to
app to do the application process to
USDA then we could at least go towards
that first step and that that piece of
it is kind of like that first step we
were discussing and your applic would
have would would that have to have
dollar a dollar value in
it because of um the way that New
Hampshire uses are free and reduced this
is specific to USDA and the
reimbursement so the adequacy portion
has nothing to do with the the USDA
portion of it so when we apply for that
we would not be indicating that in the
application process at
all okay
so my understanding is what we by
passing 601 what would we what we would
be doing would be giving the department
of Ed Authority no money authority to
proceed if in fact a Medicaid direct
certification pilot became
available to which no dollars at this
point in time would be attached Mickey
am I right or
wrong I would want some clarification on
what the department just said because it
was my understanding that if were the if
the state were to apply for this I don't
think we can say no once we're already
applied it would it would impact
adequacy at that point so I think we
would I I just I think the department
should just clarify the
last and I think we're just trying to
answer the questions about the process
piece and then there's the financial
piece so that is correct there is going
to be the financial implication for the
application process if we we are
accepted into the the program so because
of the way we utilize our free and
reduced numbers it has impacts across
the board whereas um other states in
comparison that may not use their free
and reduce numbers for their adequacy
may not have the same sort of um uh kind
of issues or attachments or things that
kind of impact one another um but
because of the way we utilize it across
the board across multiple programs yes
that they they come as a package deal so
I apologize for if I wasn't clear
earlier but thank you Mr chair and again
thank you for being here we really
appreciate your you know information and
support so am I on am I what happens is
the application binding that would be my
first quick question once we apply we
are committed to going through if we get
approved or is the application just a
you allowed to negotiate a deal and then
it comes back to the legislature or
not um from the USDA standpoint um is
what I I can speak to for that um is
that if we apply and we get approved for
it then we can move forward um
realistically back when um I believe
this was about two or three years ago um
we and I just want wanted to make this
clear also is that as the Department um
this program would not have been
something that we would have had to come
to legislative for to asked permission
we could have um applied for the program
however there was legislation that was
put forward that didn't pass therefore
we couldn't apply for the program
because we could not go around the
legislation um so I just wanted to be to
be clear um on that so when we apply for
this program
um the you can you are approved for it
um and then we we from the USDA
standpoint side and getting the federal
funding for that can start to operate
the program unless there are other um
statutes or or um regulations that are
put in place that we would need to then
come back and take the next step does
that I'm good thank you I think the
question is you said we can move forward
do we have to move forward
if we apply for the program and we're
approved can it be provisional to say
well now we have to see how it affects
the the the state overall and withdraw
from the program that was that would be
something that I can ask youda I don't I
don't know the answer to that
question other
questions
I just wanted uh to again I'm Laura
milikin from New Hampshire hunger
Solutions um I just wanted to throw out
that that USDA does or at least in the
last cycle they did allow for a portion
of alas to be a part of the pilot it
does not have to be the whole state um
the scope could either be um all schools
or um a portion so uh it it's possible
to to do a small pilot for
example well what's anybody's
pleasure I just in case you know I
thought I made a motion at the beginning
but if the motion wasn't made at the
beginning I'd like to make a motion to
IDL 601 have okay motions made in second
and fr for
itl all those in
favor those
opposed 54 so we'll recommend out to the
full finance committee of itl and I'm
sure we'll have a little more
discussion okay this has been very
educational and and I think to to
Murray's point we seem to be there's a
lot of universes cross in here and I
think we all agree we want to not have
hungry kids but this didn't look like
the solution toour so all right moving
moving
along we have House Bill
620 to set up an establishing an early
learning Department Early Learning
Department of
Education pilot
program right and you're the sponsor I
am okay and if I may please I would like
to um make a motion to interim study
House Bill
620 we have a motion for interim study
does anybody is there a
second okay represent Mery
seconds would you like to make your case
I would like to make my case um there is
a similar bill in the Senate right now
um and I have been approached by the New
Hampshire terriable trust and the cut
Foundation they're very interested in
the work that's being done here um
there's work going on at Health and
Human Services I don't think we're ready
to go forward with this program per se
but giving us time to seek more
information um I would connect with
Senator Whitley she's um I believe
Mickey if I'm correct she is interim
studying the same bill in the Senate so
we would um use our joint efforts uh a
committee here which I would be happy to
chair um and come back with a report to
the full committee and at that point in
time it would be only a recommendation
either to move forward or not to
continue so um I would hope that we
could at least invest the time in doing
a short-term interim study and come out
with a report relative to um this
program question yes um thank you for
taking my question representative Heath
um would that interim study also provide
an opportunity to consider the fiscal
ramifications of An Early Childhood
Program
absolutely I think that information as a
followup um Mr chair I think that
information could be really helpful in
terms of determining whether or not a
program um which you know we could
determine this the magnitude of the size
how many students and you know what
those fiscal ramifications will be for
our state I think that's really
important knowledge to determine whether
or not this is something um we can
achieve and um you know what the need is
thank you Mr
chair I'd like to right now doing
interim study talk about the
process what that means is that we will
have to reconvene in the fall in order
to report out the results of the interim
study
in as much as you are the sponsor of
this bill and you want to run the
interim study I got a pretty strong
feeling of what that report's going to
be so my question is from from a process
standpoint do you need the interim study
to do all the things you just said you C
you can meet with the Senate you can do
all the things you just said not worry
about I mean forget 620 the concept
moving forward for NE it's not going to
happen this this year so it's going I
mean this term it's going to be next
term
so that's I can I respond yeah
um when if in fact we recommend going
forward with the interim study we're
saying that we want to look further into
the possibilities of this bill by iing
it we are changing our status the house
passed this on the floor um if we choose
now at this point to itl it we are now
taking away the um approval that we had
once provided for this and that's
sending kind of two different messages
I'm I'm willing to do the work if if we
can just interim study there's no
funding attached to this right now we
would be able we have no figures yet
from the Department of Ved in terms of
what this would cost um Health and Human
Services is working right now
um I I don't want um representative
um uh M Jane would you have any comments
that you'd want to make based on your
work with um Health and Human
Services
no if if you would be okay if You' like
to comment
please
turn your mic
on the um idea of a pre kindergarten
program for New Hampshire children has
been going on for for quite a while um
and I think the idea of having an
interim study to really start to take a
look at what does it mean financially I
don't think we've really done that right
now the Department of Health and Human
Services does have a pilot program that
they are running but it is very small in
just um a couple of locations so it's
not it's not going to give us really the
kind of information that you might get
from an interm study so that as we look
at this in the future we'll have some
better data so so I would hope that we
could do an interim study and I think
representative Heath indicates she's
willing to put the time in and the work
in
K it came to us with the policy
decided we had to find the money we
didn't have any estimates from the
Department of Ed so we kind of stifled
an interim study what would that prove
we still wouldn't find the money the
policy's been decided I hearken back to
many years ago Head Start similar
program parents with toddlers loved it
saved a lot of daycare money but then
they went on a did a study 20 years
later after they started Head Start and
said was a waste of
money those children didn't learn any
better going forward than the ones that
were staying at home and then finally
went to kindergarten so it's a lot of
money that's going to save people for
babysitting and all the ones that that
are have little children are crazy about
it but it's a lot of money for nothing
that's what that study found out about
Head Start that's why we don't hear any
more money any more talk about Head
Start so what would you do in interim
study all you can do is say where's the
money the policy's been decided I'm
against interim study thank
you yes well thank you Mr chair I I just
would like to follow up those comments
with um a reminder to the committee that
we have not seen any fiscal information
from the state so to make blank get
declarations without a citation to a a
reputable source for whether or not this
would cost money stands to be you know
critiqued and that I think you know it's
Our obligation to consider the data and
if we don't have it an inm study is a
great way to find that data to reach out
to The Experts to combine that
information and to put it on the record
so that we have information to make a
sound decision off of um
so you know I think it's an important
and worthwhile cause to consider our
state has obviously been thinking about
it for a while and that an interim study
motion does present the opportunity for
our state to further um that mission and
to find the data that will back up the
fiscal that we are here to consider so
thank
you thank you Mr chair as a freshman uh
what timeline do we have if an interim
study happens when would it have to be
concluded it's my first term so I really
don't
know I think we have to report up by
November 1st so if we which November 1
because
it's okay no so my point is that if we
didn't get the data in the many months
we've been waiting for it what data are
we going to get in the next two weeks
that will justify interim studying it I
mean seriously what are the odds and
without data what's the point of interim
starting because we seem to all agree
that the data is needed and
it's not I'm talking about next year
next year oh next year a full year well
there you go thank
you yes and there are agencies right now
that are very committed to looking at a
pre program in the state of New
Hampshire they're willing to participate
and provide information Health and Human
Services is C currently um working on a
pilot that will bring some more
information and I think some of the
information that can be brought forward
by places like the New Hampshire
charitable trust the CCH Foundation can
provide information that we previously
didn't have that we can apply to what an
overall cost would be so I don't see any
harm in an interim study there's no
dollars attached to it we'd be pulling
in people that that would be willing to
help us um look at this and come up with
some recommendations we have till
November 1st 24 um and I think that
gives us time to come up with a good
report that we can provide to you I see
no harm and no dollars
um I see more benefit than than harm
thank
you okay so a motion been made and
seconded for interim study all those in
favor okay four four in favor all
opposed five so we'll report out to full
Finance itl for in
study anything else before the committee
I I you I gave you all are you actually
Janet did a document looks like
this that we're going to it's for next
week we're back here next Tuesday for
full
Finance is it appropriate for us to make
a formal vote for the itl because I I
don't believe there was a formal motion
and if we're going to be passing that
recommendation forward I think we
probably should have a vote on the
record very good point Thank
you can I have a motion for
itl Mr chair I move to itl Bill 620 okay
second very second
it all those in favor of
itl there's five all those opposed
four thank you keep you me
honest
now next week in finance um Mr chairman
when we have bills that were nine to
zero do we need to spend a lot of time
on or we just have to vote
them
thank God I'm not the clerk
there
I'm perod
time
toiss once the commission report is in
we will have 436 sitting there that we
could that might be
one
be so it's not going to go as quickly as
we thought
okay okay maybe we can request limiting
severely discussion when it's a
unanimous decision one way or the
othering we
alled
well my point is if your name appears as
the representative that made the motion
you may be may be asked make a comment
you don't have to make make a comment
it's really up to the up to the chair we
do have to write a
blurt
unnecessary
unnecessary Mr chair before we adjourn
for the afternoon may I just um
apologize to you and to the members of
the committee for my tardiness today as
well as for my coughing foot which I
assure you are
unrelated but um I I do apologize for um
the delay today that's sorry we we
waited till 10:30 we said well we know
you'll get here soon so
anything anything else then we are
adjourned at what is the 11th
11:30